[Music]
the post-apocalyptic world of Nier
automata thrives on its mysteries its
setting of a ruined earth is a
playground of mayhem where fashionable
androids lay waste to less sophisticated
looking robots its premise of a
never-ending war and the chic
protagonists role as a participant is
initially straightforward but if you
know anything about its director Yoko
taro then you know to expect the
unexpected the one thing you can expect
is a well-executed and refined combat
system the level of which alone makes
automata well worth the price of
admission
near automata is initially seen from the
perspective of the female Android named
to be who is part of your ha
a group of artificial soldiers task with
wiping the earth of its hostile robots
and the aliens who made them this
conflict is all the more poignant due to
humanity's displacement to the moon an
exodus that occurred hundreds of years
ago
given the rampancy of homicidal machines
making earth hospitable is a tall order
though this challenge is softened by the
manageable size of automatons open-world
which is equivalent in size to a small
city it entices exploration but not
intimidating lease oh and it's hard to
get lost once you've run through the
same paths a couple times you can credit
much of the backtracking to its
numerable side quests where you help
your fellow androids on simple errands
and kill missions while most of these
tasks aren't especially memorable they
do add character to the world the bright
side to being a robot exterminator in
automata is that your canvass of
destruction is designed by the folks at
PlatinumGames
they're experienced for fast and elegant
looking combat is on full display with
visuals that echo even the most
outrageous attacks from bayonetta combat
evolves beyond passively mashing on
quick and strong attacks thanks to the
variety of weapon styles combining any
two types produces uniquely flashy
animations and more importantly damaging
results
given its rewarding demands for high
dexterity and acrobatic skills of to be
it wouldn't be unreasonable to say that
near automata is the closest we have to
a spiritual successor to Metal Gear
Rising revengeance in the best way
possible against most enemies victories
are hard earned where you're expected to
use tools and techniques beyond the two
main attack inputs you're instilled with
a sense of confidence due to your
satellite pod companion not only does
the pod provide you with a sustained
ranged attack it's also your main outlet
for combat personalization you can swap
in a wide variety of performance
enhancement ships providing you with
stat buffs and helpful automated
commands relying on your pod to
automatically use one of your healing
items when your HP drops below a certain
point becomes one less thing to worry
about so you can focus on other survival
concerns like kicking ass and looking
good doing it
it's all the more crucial to outlive
your enemies because you'll lose your
experience points if you can't return to
the point of your last death this is
similar to the element of difficulty
popularized by Dark Souls with an added
risk of loss along with the suspense of
potentially losing experience you've
earned since your last save you can also
lose your pods non-essential chips Nier
automata resoundingly delivers that
specific flavor of stylish combat
empowerment found in Platinum's best
works
it never overshadows Tarot's distinct
directional handiwork and penchant for
unconventional game and narrative design
it's the type of production that manages
to blend in a substantial bullet hell
shooter component that somehow
complements both the hack and slash
combat and the story you don't question
the infantile behaviors of many of the
robots you come across because they're
so darn endearing and you don't get an
explanation for two B's Gothic Lolita
outfits or why some of our comrades
behave like self-involved teenagers but
you run with it as well as to be moved
swiftly through a desert and heels
Karos unorthodox approach is best
exemplified by Nier automata z' multiple
endings and of varying degrees of
substance to those conclusions he's not
above novelty or gag endings though some
of the game's best draws are the five
main endings and the various journeys to
each one to say that you don't get the
complete picture until you reach that
fifth ending isn't an overstatement
glory to mankind
thanks to platinum snack for riveting
and gratifying combat near automata is
yoko Tarot's most accessible game today
when the gameplay clicks the visual
by-product is a stylish dance where
bulette ik dodges complement wushu
inspired aggression moreover this multi
ending trip is peppered with surprises
and revelations as well as Easter eggs
that called back to the first game and
the dragon guard series from which near
spun off it's a meaty often exhilarating
Trek where a complete playthrough can
last well beyond 40 hours even with the
blistering pace of the battles
you